Hello everyone. Ladies and gentlemen, happy holidays. Ira Glass here. And this, of course, right here is the book which contains every Christmas story ever told. It's a big book. It is a very big book. And as I turn the pages for our stories today-- oh, wait a minute-- A Christmas Carol has been torn out of this book, and The Night Before Christmas . The pages are gone. The Original True Story of Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer , it's just been ripped out of here. The Grinch, Frosty the Snowman, Miracle on 34th Street-- they're all gone. How will there be Christmas without Christmas stories?
大家好。女士们、先生们，节日快乐。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，这里摆着的就是那本收录了所有圣诞故事的书。这是一本大书。它确实非常大。当我为了我们今天的故事翻动书页时……噢，等一下——《圣诞颂歌》从书里被撕掉了，《圣诞前夜》也不见了。书页没了。《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫的原创真实故事》也被人从这里生生扯掉了。《格林奇》、《雪人弗罗斯特》、《第34街的奇迹》——它们全都不见了。如果没有圣诞故事，圣诞节该怎么过呢？
Wait a minute. We can make new Christmas stories. I'll just sound the emergency horn. Hold on for a second. We'll get David Sedaris and Sarah Vowell and John Hodgman Jonathan Goldstein and Heather O'Neill to write new Christmas fables. We've got just one hour. From WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International it is a This American life Christmas Spectacular in which we head out on a mission that could not be more important. If the old Christmas classics are gone, why we'll make new classics. And with them, we are going to do nothing less than save Christmas.
等一下。我们可以创作新的圣诞故事。我得拉响紧急警报。稍等片刻。我们要让大卫·塞达里斯、莎拉·沃威尔、约翰·霍奇曼、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和希瑟·奥尼尔来写新的圣诞寓言。我们只有一个小时。这里是WBEZ芝加哥，由国际公共广播电台发行，这是一期《美国生活》圣诞特别节目，我们正要去执行一项再重要不过的任务。如果旧的圣诞经典不在了，那我们就创作新的经典。而通过它们，我们要做的正是拯救圣诞节。
And responding to this Christmas emergency distress call first is Mr. David Rackoff.
第一个回应这通圣诞紧急求助电话的是大卫·拉克奥夫先生。
10:00AM in December in midtown Manhattan, Helen sits at her desk in a dress of blue satin, a vision of evening in the mackerel light, she is garbed for the company party that night. It is too far a trek out to Avenue J just to go home to change at the end of the day. So she sits doing work, ignoring the mounting whispers and jokes led by Joan in accounting. She's aware that her dress makes the other girls laugh as they congregate over the mimeograph. Helen gamely endures not the kindest of stares with aplomb, for you see, Helen no longer cares. Well, that's mostly the truth, though some doubts still impinge, each year around Thanksgiving an unwelcome twinge starts to niggle and rankle so that by mid-December all that Helen can think is, do they still remember?
12月上午10点，曼哈顿中城，海伦坐在桌前，穿着一件蓝色缎面裙，在鲭鱼般清冷的光线下，她显得像是一个晚宴的幻影，她是为了当晚的公司派对而盛装打扮的。下班后再折腾回J大道去换衣服实在太远了。所以她坐在那里工作，无视会计部琼所领导的那群人不断传来的窃窃私语和嘲笑。她很清楚自己的裙子让其他女孩在油印机旁聚在一起时发出嘲笑。海伦从容地忍受着这些并不友善的目光，因为你看，海伦已经不在乎了。好吧，这大多是事实，尽管仍有一些疑虑在困扰她，每年感恩节前后，一种不快的刺痛感就会开始隐隐作痛和折磨她，以至于到12月中旬，海伦脑子里想的只有：他们还记得吗？
Time's gone by since that silly, regrettable business when she became known as the girl who ruined Christmas. Helen harbors the hope that the passing five years have made folks forget both the vomit and tears, and the throwing of glassware and drunken oration, that half-hour tirade of recrimination where-- feeling misused-- she got pretty plastered and named his name publicly, called him a bastard. The details are fuzzy, though others have told her how she insulted this one and cried on that shoulder, how she lurched 'round the ballroom all pitching and weaving and ended the night in the ladies' lounge, heaving. Helen turns a blind eye to the smirks and the winks. Surely by now they've forgotten, she thinks.
自从那件愚蠢、令人懊悔的事件发生以来，时间已经过去很久了，那时她被称为那个毁了圣诞节的女孩。海伦心存希望，五年过去了，人们已经忘记了那时的呕吐和泪水、摔碎玻璃杯以及酒后的演讲，那场长达半小时的互相指责的咆哮，当时——她感到被利用了——她喝得烂醉，公开叫了他的名字，骂他是混蛋。细节已经模糊了，尽管别人告诉她她是如何侮辱这个人、在那个人的肩膀上哭泣，又是如何在舞厅里摇摇晃晃地走动，最后在女士休息室呕吐着结束了那个夜晚。海伦对那些讥笑和眼色视而不见。她想，肯定到了现在，他们已经忘记了。
How had it begun, before things all turned rotten? She can pinpoint the day. She has never forgotten how he came to her desk and leaned over her chair to look over some papers and then smelled her hair. "Gardenias," he'd said-- his voice sultry and lazy-- then was back to all business. Helen felt she'd gone crazy. She was certainly never an expert at men, but an inkling was twinkling, especially when the next day he all but confirmed Helen's hunch. He leaned out of his office and asked her to lunch.
在那一切变得糟糕之前，这一切是怎么开始的呢？她能准确地指出那一天。她从未忘记他是如何走到她的办公桌前，俯身在她的椅子上查看一些文件，然后闻了闻她的头发。“栀子花，”他说——声音慵懒而性感——然后又回到工作状态。海伦觉得自己疯了。她当然从不是男人方面的专家，但一种直觉在闪烁，尤其是第二天，他几乎证实了海伦的预感。他从办公室探出头来，邀请她共进午餐。
Their talk was all awkward and formal to start. He said that he found her efficient and smart. She thanked him, then stopped. She was quite at a loss. She'd never before really talked to her boss. They each had martinis, which helped turn things mellow. He asked where she lived and if she had a fellow. He reached for her hand and asked, "Will you allow an old man to wonder who's kissing you now?"
他们的谈话一开始既尴尬又正式。他说他发现她工作高效且聪明。她向他道谢，然后停住了。她完全不知所措。她以前从没真正和老板谈过话。他们各自喝了马提尼，这让气氛变得柔和了一些。他问她住在哪里，有没有男朋友。他伸手去拿她的手，问道：“你会允许一个老人好奇是谁在吻你吗？”
It was close and convenient, his spare midtown rental. And after, more drinks at a bar near Grand Central where they sat once again in uncomfortable silence, like two guilty parties to some kind of violence. They sipped among other oblivion-seekers while June Christy sang from the bar's tinny speakers.
那是一处近便且舒适的、他在中城租的公寓。事后，他们在中央车站附近的酒吧喝了更多的酒，他们再次尴尬地沉默着，就像某种暴力的两名负罪者。他们在其他追求遗忘的人群中啜饮，背景是朱恩·克里斯蒂在酒吧劣质音箱里唱的歌。
[MUSIC- "INTERLUDE" PERFORMED BY JUNE CHRISTY]
[音乐 - 朱恩·克里斯蒂演唱的《间奏曲》]
Helen touched up her lipstick. They got to their feet and emerged from the afternoon hush to the street. He patted her cheek and said, "I'm replenished," then was off through the crowd for the next train to Greenwich. Helen pictured his house with its broad flagstone path, the windows lit up, children fresh from the bath. Helen wondered if she might just smell on his skin the copper-y scent of their afternoon sin.
海伦补了补口红。他们站起来，从下午的宁静中走出街道。他拍了拍她的脸颊说，“我感到满足了”，然后穿过人群去赶往格林威治的火车。海伦想象着他的房子，有着宽阔的石板路，窗户灯火通明，孩子们刚洗完澡。海伦想知道，她是否能从他的皮肤上闻到他们下午那场罪恶的铜锈味。
At her desk the next Monday, it was business as always. There were no words exchanged, not a glance in the hallways. With relief, Helen thought, well that's that. Never more. But next Friday found them at his pied-a-terre door, and the Friday thereafter, and the one after that, 'til sometime in late June when their actions begat what such actions are wont to, when caution's ignored. The solution was something she could not afford. They talked in his office behind his closed door. She could tell from his face that he'd been there before. In the envelope Helen found the next day on her desk was $200 and a downtown address.
接下来的周一在办公桌前，一切照旧。没有只言片语的交流，走廊里连一眼的对视都没有。海伦如释重负地想，好吧，就这样了。再也不会了。但接下来的周五又是在他的公寓门口，之后的每个周五也是如此，直到6月下旬的某个时候，他们的行为导致了这种行为通常会导致的结果，当谨慎被忽略时。这个结果是她无法承担的。他们在紧闭的办公室门后谈话。她从他的脸上看出他以前经历过这种情况。第二天，海伦在桌上发现的信封里有200美元和一个市中心的地址。
She'd never had visions of roses or cupids. From the very beginning, she wasn't that stupid. He was older, that's true. But they'd both played the game of never once speaking the other one's name. And what you don't hope for can't turn round to hurt you. This wasn't the first time she'd given her virtue. You have to want something to then feel rejected. This wasn't that different from what she'd expected. Expected, she said, and it sounded absurd. How long had it been since she'd heard that word?
她从未有过关于玫瑰或丘比特的幻想。从一开始，她就没那么愚蠢。他年纪大了，这是真的。但他们都玩着那种从不叫对方名字的游戏。你所不期盼的就不会回来伤害你。这并不是她第一次献出贞操。你必须想要得到什么才会感到被拒绝。这和她预期的并没有什么不同。预期，她说，听起来很荒谬。她有多久没听到过那个词了？
She'd heard stories of girls all summarily sacked. She was just glad for a job to which to come back. Which she did one week later. He was surly, a jerk. She should have walked out, but she needed the work. Some minimal kindness was not a tall order. Instead, he was rude or he outright ignored her until she decided that this wasn't right and stood in the door of his office one night. He was coated and hatted and ready to go when she asked, would it kill you to just say hello? He took a step backwards as if sensing danger and fixed her with eyes of a cold-blooded stranger.
她听说过女孩们被直接解雇的故事。她只是庆幸自己还有一份可以回去的工作。一周后她回去上班了。他很粗鲁，是个混蛋。她本该辞职走人，但她需要这份工作。一点微薄的善良并非过分的要求。相反，他要么很粗鲁，要么直接无视她，直到有一天晚上，她决定这不公平，站在了他的办公室门口。他穿戴好外套和帽子准备离开时，她问，打个招呼会死吗？他向后退了一步，仿佛感觉到了危险，用冷血陌生人的目光盯着她。
"I don't know what your game is, and frankly don't care, but don't threaten me, Helen. I warn you. Beware."
“我不知道你在玩什么把戏，老实说我也不在乎，但别威胁我，海伦。我警告你。小心点。”
The very next Monday, from others, she heard that-- without her agreement-- he'd had her transferred. The company didn't just outright demote her, but Helen became what is known as a floater-- doing steno for this one or helping with filing. And through it all, Helen made sure to keep smiling. The salt in the wound was the sight that then faced her-- those looks he exchanged with the girl who'd replaced her. Helen made herself steely, was ever the stoic. She held back her tears with an effort heroic. But something was growing with each passing day till it burst forth that night of her shameful display.
接下来的周一，她从别人那里听说——在未经她同意的情况下——他把她调职了。公司并没有直接降她的职，但海伦成了所谓的“机动人员”——为这个人做速记，或者帮忙归档。而在此过程中，海伦确保自己一直保持微笑。伤口上撒盐的是接下来发生的一幕——他与取代她的女孩交换了眼神。海伦让自己变得坚硬，一如既往地克制。她以英雄般的努力忍住泪水。但随着日子一天天过去，有什么东西在增长，直到在那个耻辱之夜彻底爆发。
Perhaps there are those who consider her dumb or a patsy for even agreeing to come, simply showing herself in the very same setting each year cannot help to ensure folks forgetting. But she will not stay home or remain out of sight, for to do so-- she thinks-- would prove that they're right. That was then. This is now. She needn't be pliant. So she stands there each Christmas, alone and defiant. While others quaff cocktails and gradually lose inhibitions that slowly dissolve with the booze. There's jostling and coupling, embracing with brio, all being scored by the hired jazz trio. Helen just stands, observing it all, sipping her brandy against the far wall.
也许有些人认为她笨或者是傻瓜，才会同意去赴约，每年都出现在同一个地方只会让人们无法忘记。但她不会待在家里，也不会躲起来，因为那样做——她想——就证明他们是对的。那是过去。现在是现在。她不必唯唯诺诺。所以每个圣诞节她都独自站在这里，带着反抗。当别人喝着鸡尾酒，随着酒精的作用逐渐失去抑制，随着雇佣的爵士三重奏的音乐，人群中推搡、结合、拥抱。海伦只是站在远处的墙边，啜饮着白兰地，观察着这一切。
The evening progresses, the room now quite loud. And here's Joan from accounting. She weaves through the crowd, a man on her left arm, a drink in her right, "All alone are we, Helen? No fella tonight?" Joan wears on her face an expression of utter concern, like her mouth couldn't even melt butter. Helen almost begins to explain or appease, until stopped by this knowledge-- and it makes her blood freeze-- for here is the truth Helen long had resisted, in all of their eyes she barely existed except as a source of some acid-tinged mirth. For them, she's a person devoid of real worth. They don't think of that time. Indeed, they don't care. She has always, to them, barely even been there.
夜晚继续进行，房间里变得非常吵闹。会计部的琼来了。她穿过人群，左手挽着一个男人，右手拿着一杯酒，“我们孤身一人吗，海伦？今晚没有男朋友？”琼脸上带着一种极其关切的表情，仿佛她的嘴连一块黄油都化不开。海伦几乎要开始解释或安抚，直到这认知让她血液冻结——这就是真相，海伦一直抗拒的，在他们所有人的眼里，她几乎不存在，除了作为某种酸溜溜的笑料来源。对他们来说，她是一个毫无价值的人。他们根本不想念那段时光。事实上，他们不在乎。对他们来说，她一直以来几乎都不存在。
The time when this might have been painful has passed. Nothing hurts Helen now. Her heart has been cast in bronze or in iron, or chiseled from lime, or some other substance as adamantine. Her biggest regret is the wasted five years that she's chided herself over shedding those tears. Instead of her wishing for eyes that stayed dry, she should cherish that Helen so able to cry, that Helen who felt things and then wasn't scared to express them in public, that Helen who cared.
那种可能感到痛苦的时刻已经过去了。现在没有什么能伤害海伦了。她的心已经被铸成了青铜或铁，或者用石灰雕琢，或是什么坚不可摧的物质。她最大的遗憾是浪费的那五年，因为为流泪而责备自己。她本该珍惜那个能够哭泣的海伦，那个有感觉、且不害怕在公众面前表达出来的海伦，那个曾经在乎的海伦。
She takes Joan's hands in hers with no rank or no bile. Helen looks in her eyes and breaks into a smile. "You're right," Helen says, "I should probably go home." Helen smiles one more time then adds, " [BLEEP] off Joan."
她没有怨恨，拉起琼的手。海伦看着她的眼睛，露出了微笑。“你说得对，”海伦说，“我确实该回家了。”海伦又笑了笑，然后补了一句：“滚蛋吧，琼。”
Helen takes off her dress and gets ready for bed. There is peace deep within her where once only dread. She watches the window-- for most of the night-- turn from black to pale blue in the gathering light. Then she rises, not tired, sets the coffee to perc, for once looking forward to going to work. For now she's immune to the power of them. She repeats what came to her around 3:00AM, that alone isn't dead. Alone's just alone, Helen thinks as she surveys her tidy, small home. A place for each thing and each thing in its place-- this order alone puts a smile on her face. There are others out there for whom life is more rough, so if this is my lot, well then, this is enough. She washes her cup, puts it back on the shelf. Merry Christmas to me, Helen says to herself.
海伦脱下裙子，准备睡觉。曾经只有恐惧的地方，现在内心深处满是平静。她注视着窗户——在大部分时间里——看着它从黑色变为聚集的光亮中的淡蓝色。然后她起身，并不疲倦，开始煮咖啡，第一次期待去上班。因为现在她对他们的力量免疫了。她重复着凌晨3点左右闪过脑海的想法，孤独并没有死。孤独就是孤独，海伦在环视她整洁的小屋时想。物有其位，各得其所——单是这种秩序就让她脸上露出了笑容。外面还有其他人生活得更艰难，所以如果这就是我的命运，好吧，这就足够了。她洗了杯子，放回架子上。“圣诞快乐，我自己，”海伦对自己说。
David Rackoff's latest book is called, Don't Get Too Comfortable .
大卫·拉克奥夫的最新书名为《别太舒服》。
[MUSIC- "HAVE YOURSELF A MERRY LITTLE CHRISTMAS" BY MARAH]
[音乐 - 马拉乐队演唱的《祝你有个快乐的小圣诞》]
That's the band Marah. All this hour, we're going to be hearing Christmas songs from them.
那是马拉乐队。在接下来的这一小时里，我们将一直听到他们演唱的圣诞歌曲。
If you're just tuning in, this hour we've turned to our contributors for brand new Christmas stories. Oh and I'm being-- oh thank you-- I'm being handed a note. OK, a transmission is coming in over the short wave on an emergency holiday channel from a rooftop somewhere in New York City, one of our regular contributors trying to get through to me-- bring this up on the board-- with some seldom told stories about the origins of our holiday traditions. Hold on, triangulating here. Triangulating.
如果你刚调入频道，这一个小时里我们转向了我们的撰稿人，让他们创作全新的圣诞故事。噢，我被……噢谢谢……我收到了一张字条。好吧，传输信号正在通过短波紧急频道从纽约市某处的屋顶传来，我们的一位常驻撰稿人正试图联系我——把这个显示在板上——带来一些关于我们节日传统起源的鲜为人知的故事。等等，正在三角定位。三角定位。
Are you receiving my transmission? Hello. Hello. Greetings, my name is John Hodgman. It is holiday time. And though I speak to you, as always, from my small, soundproof booth in my Upper West Side observatory, I am nonetheless surrounded by the trappings of the season. I have mixed up holiday my famous eggnog-- secret ingredient, alcoholic eggs-- and I have lit a merry little yule log here at my feet, where I am roasting chestnuts to give to the inevitable carolers and Persian Magi and crippled English children who come to the door this time of year.
你能收到我的传输信号吗？你好。你好。致以问候，我是约翰·霍奇曼。现在是节日时光。尽管我像往常一样，从我在上西区的隔音小观察室里与你们交谈，但我依然被季节的装饰所环绕。我调制了我著名的节日蛋酒——秘方：酒精蛋——并在脚下点燃了一根欢快的小圣诞圆木，在那里我正烤着栗子，准备给这个时节必经的报佳音者、波斯智者和残疾的英国孩子。
I have decked my soundproof booth with boughs of holly and, of course, poinsettia or, some say, poin-settia. Though it is actually pronounced pon-see-ha. Did you know that it is a Mexican plant? It is. Named for the ambassador to Mexico, James Poinsett, it was brought to our country in 1828 and quickly became favored over its predecessor, the Christ-odendron.
我用冬青树枝装饰了我的隔音室，当然还有一品红（Poinsettia）。虽然也有人说是Poin-settia。不过它的正确读音其实是“pon-see-ha”。你知道它是一种墨西哥植物吗？是的。它以墨西哥大使詹姆斯·波因塞特命名，于1828年被带到我国，并很快受到了青睐，取代了它的前身：基督树（Christ-odendron）。
Some might argue we've ended up with an inferior, less godly plant. But in fact, history shows us so little of Christmas is actually Christian. Most scholars now agree, after all, that Jesus could not have been born on December 25, pointing out that shepherds did not tend their flocks in winter, and thus, could not possibly have seen the star of Bethlehem. And of course, there is no way that Christ was a Capricorn.
有些人可能会说我们最终得到了一种劣质的、不那么神圣的植物。但事实上，历史向我们展示，圣诞节中实际上很少有真正基督教的东西。毕竟，大多数学者现在一致认为，耶稣不可能出生在12月25日，指出牧羊人不会在冬天看管羊群，因此，绝不可能看到伯利恒之星。当然，基督也不可能是摩羯座。
Take this mistletoe above my head, for example. It was the symbol of Frigga, the Norse goddess of love. And it was equally prized by ancient druids as a bane against witchcraft and lightening, which I find especially comforting, as both are out to get me. It was not until the middle of the 19th century that the Christmas tree itself was generally accepted into the American home.
比如我头顶上的这株槲寄生。它是挪威爱之女神弗丽嘉的象征。它也同样受到古代德鲁伊的珍视，将其作为抵御巫术和雷电的护身符，我觉得这特别令人欣慰，因为这两者都想找我麻烦。直到19世纪中叶，圣诞树才普遍被美国家庭所接受。
The tradition originates in Germany. Originally a pagan custom, for many years German Christmas trees were dark or else lit only by natural luminous mosses. It was Martin Luther, the great reformer, who first suggested draping the dry branches with lighted candles, presumably because he felt the custom was not sufficiently dangerous for the thrill-happy protestants.
这个传统源于德国。最初是一种异教习俗，多年来德国的圣诞树要么是黑漆漆的，要么只由自然的发光苔藓点亮。是伟大的宗教改革家马丁·路德首先建议在干燥的树枝上悬挂点燃的蜡烛，大概是因为他觉得这种习俗对于寻求刺激的新教徒来说不够危险。
Still, most considered the tree a crude, Germanic fancy until 1850, when Prince Albert-- consort to Queen Victoria-- brought the Christmas tree to England. Albert, of course, was a Bavarian by birth. Many in England feared his foreign influence upon the queen and the nation. This wounded Albert. And the wee hours of Christmas Eve, 1850, found him at Osborne House, the great Germanic castle he had designed on the Isle of Wight. He was unable to sleep and overcome with despair. Despite the children he had given to the nation, despite his beautiful morning coats, and for all of Victoria's devotion to him, it seemed he would always be loathed as an alien. Now he faced another drab, tree-less, English Christmas.
尽管如此，大多数人还是认为这种树是一种粗俗的日耳曼幻想，直到1850年，维多利亚女王的配偶阿尔伯特亲王将圣诞树带到了英国。阿尔伯特当然是巴伐利亚裔。英国许多人担心他对女王和国家施加外来影响。这伤害了阿尔伯特。1850年平安夜的深夜，他身处奥斯本宫，那是他在怀特岛设计的一座宏伟的日耳曼城堡。他无法入睡，被绝望笼罩。尽管他为国家带来了子嗣，尽管他有漂亮的晨礼服，而且尽管维多利亚对他忠心耿耿，但他似乎永远会被当作异类而遭到憎恶。现在他面临着另一个沉闷、没有树的英国圣诞节。
And having consumed perhaps one too many alcoholic eggs, the prince consort fled the house, wandering desolately under the starless night until he reached the sea. There he peered from the esplanade into the icy, churning waves, "What use am I to anyone?" He said quietly in German. He fingered the Bavarian life insurance policy in his coat pocket. "I am worth more dead than alive. I wish I had never been born."
在喝了大概太多杯酒精蛋酒后，这位王夫逃离了房子，在无星的夜空下忧郁地游荡，直到来到海边。在那里，他从海滨长廊凝视着冰冷、翻滚的海浪，“我对任何人有什么用？”他用德语轻声说。他抚摸着大衣口袋里的巴伐利亚人寿保险单。“我死比活着更有价值。我希望我从未出生过。”
And at that moment, he instructed his footman, Clive-- who had, of course, accompanied Albert-- to suicide his master on the spot. But before he could act, Albert was startled to see another figure on the key toss himself into the abyss. Stirred from melancholy, Albert leapt in after him and saved the strange man from drowning. As they dried off at a nearby guard house, Albert regarded him-- a foolish little man in flowing white robes.
就在那一刻，他指示他的男仆克莱夫——当然，克莱夫一直陪着阿尔伯特——当场了结他的主人。但在他行动之前，阿尔伯特惊讶地看到海滩上的另一个人投身于深渊中。被忧郁所惊动，阿尔伯特跳下去救了那个奇怪的人。当他们在附近的卫兵室擦干身体时，阿尔伯特打量着他——一个穿着飘逸白袍的愚蠢小个子。
"A druid?" asked Albert.
“德鲁伊？”阿尔伯特问。
"Only a Druid Second Class," corrected the druid, who called himself Cathbad. The time of the true druids had long been over, he explained. But there were still a few adepts like himself, hoping to earn his golden sickle It was then that Cathbad reminded Albert that, long before there was Christmas, the long nights of December were illuminated by other holidays. Albert's own Germanic Yule, for example, or the Roman feast of Sol Invictus, both celebrating the return of the sun in the darkest part of the year.
“只是二级德鲁伊，”那个自称卡斯巴德的德鲁伊纠正道。他解释说，真正德鲁伊的时代早已结束。但仍有一些像他这样的修行者，希望能赚到他的金镰刀。那时，卡斯巴德提醒阿尔伯特，早在圣诞节出现之前，12月的长夜就被其他节日照亮了。例如阿尔伯特自己的日耳曼尤尔节，或者是罗马的无敌太阳神节，两者都是在一年中最黑暗的时刻庆祝太阳的回归。
"Remember," said Cathbad, "Christmas is not a birthday so much as it is a rebirth day. Like the evergreen itself, this holiday is a celebration of endurance, of life, of hope, in winter's longest night, which itself is not an un-Christian sentiment," said Cathbad. "But wouldn't it be better celebrated with a great big fir tree, all the same?"
“记住，”卡斯巴德说，“圣诞节与其说是一个生日，不如说是一个重生之日。像常青树本身一样，这个节日是对冬夜最长时刻中生命、希望与忍耐的颂歌，这本身并非反基督教的情感，”卡斯巴德说。“但无论如何，如果用一棵大大的冷杉树来庆祝不是更好吗？”
And so at last, Albert ceased trying to belong and embraced his German heritage, pulling a great silver fir from the frozen earth with his bare hands and dragging it back to Osborne house, where he festooned it with candles and household servants.
于是，阿尔伯特终于停止了尝试归属，转而拥抱了他的德国传统，徒手从冰冻的土地中拔出一棵巨大的银冷杉，将其拖回奥斯本宫，用蜡烛和家庭仆人装饰起来。
Images of Albert and Victoria embracing paganism within the royal home were circulated in magazines throughout the world, quickly becoming the picture of Victorian Christmastime that every American home would anxiously aspire to. Both Christmas trees and, curiously, Albert would soon become immensely popular. And it is still said that every time a bell rings, a Second Class Druid gets his golden sickle and a British heathen witch king finally finds the love of his people.
阿尔伯特和维多利亚在皇室家中拥抱异教的图片在世界各地的杂志上流传，迅速成为每个美国家庭都会焦虑渴望的维多利亚时代圣诞节的写照。圣诞树和——有趣的是——阿尔伯特很快都变得极其受欢迎。至今仍有人说，每当铃铛响起，一个二级德鲁伊就会得到他的金镰刀，而一个英国异教巫王终于找到了他人民的爱。
Ah, I hear the carollers coming and my soundproof booth is now on fire. But before we part, allow me to share with you some of Prince Albert's own advice for caring for and keeping your tree fresh and healthy throughout the season.
啊，我听到报佳音者来了，我的隔音室现在着火了。但在我们分开之前，允许我与你们分享一些阿尔伯特亲王本人关于在整个季节里照顾和保持你的树新鲜健康的建议。
First, before displaying your tree, always cut off about two inches of the stump. Always keep the tree well-watered. Remember also that it watches you and keeps within its dark and sticky pitch the memory of a thousand winters. And finally, despite what you may have heard elsewhere, you should never add sugar to the tree's water, or aspirin, or any other sort of food, unless it is a little human blood.
首先，在展示你的树之前，一定要切掉约两英寸的树桩。一定要保持树木水分充足。也要记住它在注视着你，并将一千个冬天的记忆保存在它黑暗而粘稠的松脂中。最后，尽管你在其他地方可能听说过，但你永远不应该在树的水里加糖、阿司匹林或任何其他食物，除非是一点点人血。
Now I must bid you farewell. God bless us, every one. And Merry Christmas, you old building and loan. From a soundproof booth that is now on fire, that is all.
现在我必须向你们告别了。愿上帝保佑我们每一个人。圣诞快乐，你们这些老旧的建筑和贷款。从一间正在着火的隔音室里，这就是全部了。
John Hodgman. He's the author of the book, The Areas of My Expertise . Coming up, David Sedaris and Jesus. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
约翰·霍奇曼。他是《我的专业领域》一书的作者。接下来，大卫·塞达里斯和耶稣。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
I'm Ira Glass and you're listening to a This American Life Christmas Spectacular. We have sounded the alarm asking our contributors for brand new Christmas stories, because they and they alone can save Christmas. This next one-- about a savior come to earth living as a human-- is about the difficulty of being a savior, or a profit, or anything like that, amongst us humans. It's from Heather O'Neill.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，你正在收听的是《美国生活》圣诞特别节目。我们拉响了警报，向我们的撰稿人寻求全新的圣诞故事，因为只有他们，也唯有他们，才能拯救圣诞节。下一个故事——关于一个降临人间像人类一样生活的救世主——讲述的是作为一个救世主、先知或类似的人在我们人类中间是多么困难。它来自希瑟·奥尼尔。
Jesus and I were pretty good friends. And after he disappeared from our neighborhood and all those TV reporters started showing up on our street, I was a pretty hot property. My mom would freak out and call them vultures when they tried to ask me questions. But I'd try and chill her out. "Be cool," I'd say. And it wasn't just that I liked being on TV, I truly liked talking about Jesus. I still do. And to this day, people are always asking me to tell them everything I know about him.
耶稣和我曾是相当好的朋友。在他从我们社区消失，所有那些电视记者开始出现在我们的街道上后，我成了个抢手货。我妈妈会发疯，当他们试图问我问题时叫他们秃鹫。但我会试着让她冷静下来。“酷一点，”我会说。不仅仅是因为我喜欢上电视，我真心喜欢谈论耶稣。我现在依然喜欢。直到今天，人们总是求我告诉他们我所知道的关于他的一切。
Jesus and I were in grade six when we first met. And back then, not everyone was allowed to hang out with me. A part of the reason was the way I dressed. I was the only girl in class who had a pair of high heels. And for my birthday, my mother bought me a ton of black bracelets with studs on them. Other people's parents said I looked like a whore and they didn't want their kids to get my whore cooties or something. But my attitude has always been just to be who you got to be. A part of this way of thinking comes from me. But a good part of it also comes from the stuff that Jesus taught me. But more on that later.
我和耶稣在六年级时第一次见面。那时候，不是每个人都被允许和我混在一起。部分原因是我穿衣服的方式。我是班上唯一一个有一双高跟鞋的女孩。我生日时，妈妈给我买了一大堆带钉子的黑色手镯。其他人的父母说我看起来像个妓女，他们不想让他们的孩子染上我的妓女病菌之类的东西。但我的态度一向是只要做你自己就行了。这种思维方式的一部分来自我。但很大一部分也来自耶稣教我的东西。不过以后再细说。
Jesus first showed up in the middle of the school year and sat in the back of the class. On that first day, when our chemistry teacher put on this movie about molecules, Jesus held up his hands in front of the projector and made a shadow puppet of a dove. That's how I first noticed him. It was about a week later when everybody started to notice Jesus.
耶稣是在学年中期第一次出现，坐在教室后面。那天我们的化学老师放了一部关于分子的电影，耶稣在投影仪前举起双手，做了一个鸽子的手影。那就是我第一次注意到他。大约一周后，每个人都开始注意到耶稣了。
In moral ed., we had to give a presentation on a social concern. And Jesus did his on world hunger. He went up to the front of the classroom without a loose leaf paper or anything and started going on about how there wasn't such a thing as world hunger, which as well as being a downright weird thing to say was also factually incorrect. We'd all seen pictures of Ethiopia on the news. And those poor kids were definitely hungry. Jesus said that if God fed the sparrows and butterflies, then he would also feed humans. The teacher pointed out that a lot of animals had gone extinct because the environment hadn't provided for them. But Jesus shrugged and went back to his seat. So we just figured he was really stupid.
在道德教育课上，我们必须做一个关于社会问题的演讲。耶稣做的是关于世界饥饿。他没带活页纸什么的直接走上讲台，开始滔滔不绝地说世界上根本不存在所谓的饥饿，这不仅是个听起来极其奇怪的说法，而且在事实上也是错误的。我们都曾在新闻里看过埃塞俄比亚的照片。那些可怜的孩子确实在挨饿。耶稣说如果上帝喂养麻雀和蝴蝶，那么他也会喂养人类。老师指出很多动物因为环境无法供应它们而灭绝了。但耶稣耸耸肩，回到座位上。所以我们只觉得他真的很蠢。
Since Jesus and I lived on the same block, we'd walk home from school together. One day on our way home he invited me over to his house to play with his Ouija Board. As we walked to his house, Jesus told me that his father didn't really love his mother. He didn't believe that Jesus was his child. He told me that while swinging his lunch pail. He told me that the same way you'd tell someone that you liked apples. When someone tells you something like that-- all casual-- it sort of takes the pressure off. You don't have to start rocking them in your arms and stuff. I appreciated Jesus for going easy on me like that, since we've all got our own troubles.
因为耶稣和我住在同一条街上，我们一起放学回家。有一天在回家的路上，他邀请我去他家玩他的通灵板。在我们走去他家时，耶稣告诉我他父亲其实并不爱他母亲。他不相信耶稣是他的孩子。他在甩着午餐盒时这么对我说的。他告诉我的语气就像告诉别人他喜欢苹果一样。当有人这么漫不经心地告诉你这种事时，它倒减轻了心理负担。你不必开始摇着他抱在怀里之类的。我感激耶稣对我如此轻松，因为我们都有自己的麻烦。
His family lived in a building that had a huge billboard advertising beer on the roof. And there were dogs walking around in the stairwell like they owned the joint. We went into his room, closed off all the lights, and set up the Ouija Board. As soon as we touched the marker, it started zipping around like a cockroach high on roach poison. I'd never seen such a thing before. Jesus and I took our fingers off the marker, but it kept sliding around just the same. It spelled out, "I am with you Jesus."
他的家人住在一栋屋顶上有巨大的啤酒广告牌的楼里。楼梯间里有狗走来走去，好像它们是那里的主人。我们进了他的房间，关掉所有的灯，架好了通灵板。我们刚摸到指针，它就开始像中了杀蟑剂的蟑螂一样到处乱窜。我以前从未见过这种事。耶稣和我把手指从指针上拿开，但它依然在滑动。它拼出了：“我和你在一起，耶稣。”
Jesus and I screamed our heads off. We jumped off the couch and ran right into the apartment hallway. Under the stairwell, I let Jesus put his hand against my T-shirt to see how hard my heart was beating.
耶稣和我吓得大叫。我们跳下沙发，直接跑进了公寓走廊。在楼梯下，我让耶稣把手按在我的T恤上，看看我的心跳得有多快。
Jesus continued to get into trouble for ridiculous things at school like photocopying his head in a copier in the school library and giving himself a haircut in art class. He wore his ski mask one day-- even though it was April already-- and impersonated Gollum's voice underneath it. I told my mom about it and she said he might be schizophrenic. But she changed her mind about him when she met him.
耶稣继续在学校因荒谬的事情惹麻烦，比如在学校图书馆的复印机上复印自己的头，在美术课上给自己剪头发。有一天他戴着滑雪面罩——尽管已经是四月了——并在下面模仿咕噜的声音。我告诉了我妈，她说他可能是精神分裂症。但当她见到他时，她改变了对他看法。
One really warm spring day, Jesus showed up at my apartment. I never invited people over. So I was a little put off having Jesus in our house. Once I had Georgie over and he said he found our apartment depressing.
一个非常温暖的春天日子，耶稣出现在我的公寓。我从不邀请人来。所以耶稣在我们家让我感到有点不自在。有一次我让乔治来过，他说他觉得我们公寓很压抑。
"I like your place," Jesus said, leaning against my bedroom window pane, "You have a great view from here, right out onto the record store. It probably helps you dream of music. We have the best neighborhood."
“我喜欢这儿，”耶稣靠在我的卧室窗玻璃上说，“你这里的视野很好，直对唱片店。这大概能帮你梦想音乐。我们住的街区最棒了。”
"Wouldn't you rather we lived in Westmount?" I asked. Westmount was the fanciest neighborhood in the city. And my mother was always going on about how-- if she won the Lucky Seven-- she'd set fire to the building and move us there in a smoke cloud of glory.
“你难道不想让我们住在西山区吗？”我问。西山区是城里最豪华的街区。我妈妈老是说如果她中了“幸运七”彩票，她就会烧了这栋楼，在光荣的烟雾中搬到那里去。
"Being rich is stupid," he said. "It's way better to have less. It makes you cooler. No one from a rich background can ever really be cool." He said all of this just the way he dropped the news about his dad, very matter of fact. Maybe that was why I bought it. It seemed to just make sense, like he was saying something that I had already thought of myself, but I'd never actually gotten around to putting into complete sentences. Jesus' words made me feel like, no matter how much there was something deep down wrong with you, there really wasn't anything wrong with you at all.
“有钱很傻，”他说。“拥有得少更好。这让你更酷。没有任何有钱背景的人能真正酷起来。”他说这些话时，就像他告诉关于他父亲的消息那样，非常客观。也许这就是我信他的原因。这似乎说得通，就像他在说一些我自己已经想到，但从未真正有机会用完整句子表达出来的事情。耶稣的话让我觉得，无论你内心深处有什么问题，其实你根本就没有任何问题。
Jesus liked absolutely everybody in our school in a way that I'd never seen before or since. I learned this one day at lunch time. It was sunny and beautiful out so we went to sit on the picnic tables that were at the end of the school yard.
耶稣以一种我从未见过的方式喜欢学校里的每一个人。这事我是在某天午餐时间发现的。阳光明媚，非常美丽，所以我们去坐在操场尽头的野餐桌旁。
"Uh, we'd better turn right back," I said, "Look who's at the table." It was Sam, a boy no one talked to. He lived across the street from the school, so his mother assumed she didn't have to get dressed when she came over. She'd show up with his lunch in her housecoat and slippers. His dad had a beard that came down to his chest. And he walked down the street looking straight ahead of him, never using his neck. And once at the grocery store, I'd seen them using a sock as a wallet.
“呃，我们最好直接回去，”我说，“看看桌边是谁。”那是山姆，一个没人说话的男孩。他住在学校街对面，所以他妈妈认为她过来时不必换衣服。她会穿着晨衣和拖鞋带着他的午餐过来。他爸爸留着长到胸口的胡子。他走在街上时总是直视前方，脖子从不转动。有一次在杂货店，我见过他们用袜子当钱包。
"I think he's all right," Jesus said. "He reminds me of Willy Wonka."
“我觉得他挺好的，”耶稣说。“他让我想起威利·旺卡。”
"I saw him trying to burn the bottom of his shoes with a lighter," I said. There was no stopping Jesus. So we walked over towards him. Sam looked at us both, expecting us to tell him to get lost.
“我看见他试图用打火机烧鞋底，”我说。耶稣没理我。所以我们朝他走去。山姆看着我们俩，以为我们要叫他滚开。
"Can we sit with you?" Jesus asked, sitting down.
“我们可以坐这儿吗？”耶稣问道，坐了下来。
"OK," Sam said wearily.
“行，”山姆疲惫地说。
"Do you like the White Stripes?" I asked, to make conversation.
“你喜欢白线条乐队吗？”为了找话聊，我问道。
"When they're in the middle of the street I guess I do," he said nervously, not knowing what the hell I was getting at, as though this was a setup to a joke that would end with me brushing liquid paper across his face. I spent the lunch looking at my feet, not really knowing what one should say to the insane. Jesus just smiled, peacefully chewing his peanut butter sandwich.
“当他们在街中间时我想我喜欢，”他紧张地说，根本不知道我在说什么，仿佛这是一个以我会在他脸上涂修正液结束的笑话的铺垫。我整个午餐都看着自己的脚，不知道该对疯子说些什么。耶稣只是微笑着，平静地嚼着他的花生酱三明治。
"Did you ever go to a fair last year?" Sam said suddenly. "They have these fancy horses with hair that goes down to their feet." He took a photograph out of his pocket of the skinniest, prettiest white horse I'd ever seen. It was more beautiful than a unicorn. What could I say? The world was filled with mysteries.
“去年你去过集市吗？”山姆突然说。“他们有那种漂亮的马，毛长到脚下。”他从口袋里掏出一张照片，是我见过最瘦、最漂亮的白马。它比独角兽更美。我能说什么呢？世界充满了奥秘。
Then our teacher, Mrs. Dumont, went on maternity leave. And we got stuck with Mrs. Allison. On the first day, she told the class that this boy, Quincy, hadn't paid his lunch fees yet. She said the only way you could be excused from lunch fees was if your father didn't work. She asked if this was the case and Quincy just shifted in his seat. She told him to bring in a note the next day from his dad explaining that he didn't have a job. Every day for the rest of the week she would ask Quincy where the note was.
然后我们的老师杜蒙太太去休产假了。我们被塞给了艾莉森太太。第一天，她告诉全班这个男孩昆西还没交午餐费。她说只有父亲没工作的学生才能免除午餐费。她问情况是否如此，昆西只是在座位上挪动了一下。她叫他明天带张他爸爸写的纸条来，解释他没有工作。这一周剩下的每天她都会问昆西纸条在哪里。
Another thing Mrs. Allison had a problem with was the way Jesus fluttered from desk to desk, helping the weaker kids with their long division. Mrs. Dumont used to look the other way with this. But Mrs. Allison said that, as well as being disruptive, it wasn't giving her an accurate sense of who the class knuckleheads were.
艾莉森太太有问题的另一件事是耶稣在课桌间飞来飞去，帮助较弱的学生做除法。杜蒙太太以前对此睁一只眼闭一只眼。但艾莉森太太说，这不仅破坏纪律，也没让她准确了解班里的笨蛋都是谁。
"Where's your lunch?" asked Jesus. I was sitting in the cafeteria with my head down on the table.
“你的午餐呢？”耶稣问。我坐在食堂里，头趴在桌子上。
"Mrs. Allison," I said. "She tossed it." I explained how she saw me eating a mock chicken sandwich and how she held it up for everyone to see. I explained how she picked it up with the tips of her fingers, like it was a dirty sweat sock, and said she was going to send me home with one of those nutrition wheels to give my mother so she could know better.
“艾莉森太太，”我说。“她给扔了。”我解释了她是如何看到我吃人造鸡肉三明治，又是如何把它举起来给所有人看。我解释了她如何用指尖捏着它，就像捏一只脏袜子，说她要送我回家，给我妈妈带一张营养轮，好让她知道点好歹。
Jesus stormed off. I followed him down the hallway. He kicked open the door to the teachers' lounge and walked right in. A terrible whiff of stale cigarette smoke hit me. It was the first time that anyone had ever stood up for me. It was terrifying and wonderful at the same time. It made me feel like I'd found a $100 bill and was being chased by a rabid dog all at once.
耶稣气冲冲地走了。我跟着他走进走廊。他踢开教师休息室的门，直接走了进去。一阵可怕的陈年香烟味扑面而来。这是第一次有人为我挺身而出。这既可怕又美妙。这让我觉得就像我捡到一张100美元钞票，同时又被一条疯狗追赶一样。
All the kids in the hall got hysterical when they saw that Jesus had just walked into the teachers' lounge. It was magically off limits. They all started banging on their lockers and calling out for joy, like the power had just gone off. But this was even better than that. It was as if the whole building was coming down.
走廊里的所有孩子看到耶稣走进教师休息室都歇斯底里了。那是神奇的禁区。他们开始敲打柜子，为之欢呼，就像电力突然中断了一样。但这比那更好。这就像整栋大楼都要塌了一样。
There are all kinds of stories about what Jesus had said to Mrs. Allison in the teachers' lounge that day. In my mind, I imagined her crumpling to her knees as he made her realize everything bad she'd ever done to me.
关于耶稣那天在教师休息室对艾莉森太太说的话，有各种各样的说法。在我脑海里，我想象她跪倒在地，因为他让她意识到她对我做过的所有坏事。
Jesus was suspended from school for a week. In class, Mrs. Allison said Jesus wasn't the big shot we all thought. The principal agreed with her that he was a troublemaker and that he was messing with everyone's heads. His father wouldn't let him stay at home alone during the day. He said he didn't want Jesus messing up the house. So Jesus rode the bus back and forth and hung around downtown. I heard how he hung out in the pool hall and the older teenagers would hoist him onto the table and he would just talk. They said he was funnier than Robin Williams. But if I knew Jesus, he was just telling it like it was.
耶稣被停课一周。在课堂上，艾莉森太太说耶稣并不是我们想象的那样大人物。校长同意她的看法，说他是捣乱分子，是在扰乱大家的思想。他父亲白天不让他独自待在家里。他说他不想让耶稣把房子搞乱。所以耶稣坐公交车来回奔波，在市中心转悠。我听说他常待在台球厅，大点的青少年会把他举到桌子上，他就只是在那谈话。他们说他比罗宾·威廉姆斯还搞笑。但如果我了解耶稣的话，他只是在陈述事实。
Then on the third day of his suspension, Jesus never came home. The story went that he was abducted. But nobody could really say for sure. The thing is, he would have been really easy to kidnap. Jesus trusted everyone. There are pictures of Jesus plastered to every telephone pole in the city, and practically the whole school had to be treated for Post-Traumatic Stress Disorder. Sam said he saw Jesus in the park a little while after he vanished, picking up litter. But you couldn't believe what Sam said. He'd become totally obsessed with Jesus after the disappearance. Every composition he wrote in class was about him. The teacher said it was just his way of coping with the stress.
然后在他停课的第三天，耶稣再也没回来。传言说他被绑架了。但没人能确定。问题是，绑架他太容易了。耶稣信任每一个人。耶稣的照片贴满了城里的每一根电线杆，几乎全校的孩子都不得不接受创伤后应激障碍治疗。山姆说耶稣消失后不久他在公园看见过耶稣，在捡垃圾。但你不能相信山姆说的。他消失后完全迷上了耶稣。他写的每一篇作文都是关于他的。老师说这只是他应对压力的一种方式。
I guess I was dealing with some serious stress of my own, because one day in art class, when the teacher told me that little girls who wore black tank tops didn't get into college, I looked right back at him and said, "What makes you so perfect? You've done too many lousy things yourself to be judging children." And the teacher got all red in the face because he knew it was the truth.
我想我也在处理严重的压力，因为有一天在美术课上，当老师告诉我穿黑色背心的小女孩考不上大学时，我直接看着他说：“是什么让你如此完美？你自己做了太多烂事，没资格评判孩子。”老师脸都气红了，因为他知道那是事实。
"Stick to your teaching from now on," said someone from the back of the class. And we all nodded and muttered our consent. I knew that Jesus would have loved that. These were the kinds of things that he would say. And it felt good to say them.
“从现在起专心教你的书吧，”后排有人说。我们都点头表示赞同。我知道耶稣会喜欢那样。这些正是他会说的话。说出来感觉真好。
Heather O'Neill has a new book coming out from HarperCollins called Lullabies for Little Criminals .
希瑟·奥尼尔有一本哈珀柯林斯出版的新书，叫《小罪犯的摇篮曲》。
[MUSIC- "SILVER BELLS" BY MARAH]
[音乐 - 马拉乐队演唱的《银铃》]
You're listening to a This American Life Christmas Spectacular. And of course, the classic Christmas stories are like little Christmas fables. And with our next, brand new story to save Christmas we have David Sedaris.
你正在收听的是《美国生活》圣诞特别节目。当然，经典的圣诞故事就像小的圣诞寓言。为了拯救圣诞节的下一个全新的故事，我们邀请了大卫·塞达里斯。
The cow was notoriously cheap. So it surprised everyone when she voted, yes, for the secret santa program. It was the horse's suggestion and she backed it immediately saying, "I choose the turkey."
那头牛以吝啬出名。所以当她投票赞成秘密圣诞老人计划时，每个人都很惊讶。这是马的提议，她立即表示支持说：“我选火鸡。”
"That's not exactly the way it works," the pig explained. "It's secret, see? So we each draw a name and keep it to ourselves until Christmas morning."
“事情不是那样运作的，”猪解释说。“这是秘密的，明白吗？所以我们每人抽一个名字，在圣诞节早晨之前都要保密。”
"Why do you have to be like that?" the cow asked.
“你为什么要那样？”牛问。
And the duck sighed, "Here we go."
鸭子叹了口气，“又来了。”
"First you ask me to give someone a Christmas present," the cow continued, "And then you tell me it has to be done your way. Like, oh, I have four legs so I'm better than everyone else."
“首先你让我送别人圣诞礼物，”牛继续说，“然后你告诉我必须按你的方式来做。比如，哦，我有四条腿，所以我比谁都强。”
"Don't you have four legs?" the pig asked.
“你难道没有四条腿吗？”猪问。
"All right, just because you have a curly tail," the cow said. The pig tried looking behind him. But all he could see were his sides.
“好吧，就因为你有一条卷尾巴，”牛说。猪试着向后看。但他只能看到自己的侧面。
"Is it curly, curly?" he asked the rooster, "Or curly, kinky?"
“它是那种卷吗？”他问公鸡，“还是那种扭曲的卷？”
"The point is that I'm a little tired of being pushed around," the cow said. "I think a lot of us are." This was her all over. So rather than spending the next week listening to her complain, it was decided that the cow would give to the turkey and that everyone else would keep their name a secret.
“重点是我有点厌倦被指使了，”牛说。“我想我们很多人都厌倦了。”这就是她的一贯风格。所以与其花下周时间听她抱怨，大家决定让牛送给火鸡，而其他人各自保密自己的名字。
There were, of course, no shops in the barnyard, which was a shame as all of the animals had money-- coins mainly, dropped by the farmer and his children as they went about their chores. The cow once had close to $3 and gave it to a calf the farmer planned on taking into town.
当然，谷仓里没有商店，这真可惜，因为所有的动物都有钱——主要是硬币，是农夫和孩子们做杂活时掉落的。牛曾经有过快3美元，把它给了农夫打算带到城里去的一头小牛。
"I want you to buy me a knapsack," she told him, "Just like the one that the farmer's daughter has, only bigger and blue instead of green. Can you remember that?" The calf had tucked the money into his cheek before being led out of the barn. "And wouldn't you know it," the cow later complained, "Isn't it just my luck that he never came back?"
“我要你给我买个背包，”她告诉他，“就像农夫女儿背的那种，只是更大，蓝色的而不是绿色的。你能记住吗？”小牛在被带出谷仓前把钱藏在腮里。“你猜怎么着，”牛后来抱怨道，“我倒霉就倒霉在，他再也没回来。”
She'd spent the first few days of his absence in a constant, almost giddy, state of anticipation. Watching the barn door, listening for the sound of the truck, waiting for that knapsack, something that would belong only to her. When it no longer made sense to hope, she turned to self pity then rage. The calf had taken advantage of her, had spent her precious money on a bus ticket and boarded thinking, so long, sucker.
她在小牛离开后的头几天一直处于一种恒定的、近乎眩晕的期待状态。盯着谷仓门，听着卡车的声响，等待着那个背包，那件只属于她的东西。当希望不再有意义时，她转向了自我怜悯，然后是愤怒。小牛占了她的便宜，把她珍贵的钱花在了车票上，登车时想的是：再见了，傻瓜。
It was a consolation then to overhear the farmer talking to his wife and learn that taking an animal into town was a euphemism for hitting him in the head with an electric hammer. So long, sucker.
后来偶然听到农夫跟妻子谈话，才知道把动物带进城是一个委婉说法，意思是拿电锤往它们头上砸，这就成了一种安慰。再见了，傻瓜。
Milking put the cow in close proximity to humans, much closer than any of the other animals. And she learned a lot by keeping her ears open-- local gossip, the rising cost of fuel oil, and countless little things, the menu for Christmas dinner, for instance. The family had spent Thanksgiving visiting the farmer's mother in her retirement home and had eaten what tasted like potato chips soaked in chicken fat. Now they were going to make up for it. "Big time," the farmer's wife said. And with all the trimmings.
挤奶让牛与人类有了近距离接触，比其他动物都要近。她通过竖起耳朵学到了很多——本地八卦、燃油成本的上涨，以及无数小事，比如圣诞晚餐的菜单。那家人刚花了感恩节去疗养院看望了农夫的母亲，吃的是尝起来像浸在鸡油里的薯片的东西。现在他们要补回来。“大补，”农夫的妻子说。“还要配上所有配菜。”
The turkey didn't know that he would be killed on Christmas Eve. No one did, except for the cow. That's why she'd specifically chosen his name for the secret Santa program. It got her off the hook and made it more fun to watch his pointless, fidgety enthusiasm.
火鸡不知道他会在平安夜被杀。没人知道，除了牛。这就是为什么她在秘密圣诞老人计划中特别选择了他的名字。这让她置身事外，也让她更有趣地观察他那种毫无意义、焦躁不安的热情。
"You'll never in a million years guess what I got you," she said to him a day after the names were drawn.
“你这一辈子都猜不到我送你什么，”名字抽出来一天后，她对他说。
"Is it a bath mat?" the turkey asked. He'd seen one hanging on the clothesline and was obsessed with it for some reason. "It's a towel for the floor," he kept telling everyone. "I mean really, isn't that just the greatest idea you ever heard in your life?"
“是地垫吗？”火鸡问。他见过一张挂在晾衣绳上，出于某种原因他着了魔。“它是给地板用的毛巾，”他不断告诉每个人。“我的意思是，这难道不是你一生中听过的最伟大的点子吗？”
"Oh, this is a lot better than a bath mat," the cow said, chuckling as the turkey sputtered, "No way," and "What could possibly be better than a bath mat?"
“哦，这比地垫好多了，”牛说着，当火鸡惊叫“不可能”和“还有什么能比地垫更好”时，她咯咯直笑。
"You'll seek come Christmas morning," she told him.
“等到圣诞节早晨你就知道了，”她告诉他。
Most of the animals were giving food as their secret Santa gift. No one came out and actually said it, but the cow had noticed them setting a little aside. Not just scraps, but the best parts-- oats from the horse, thick crusts of bread from the pig. Even the rooster-- who was the biggest glutton of all-- had managed to sacrifice and had stockpiled a fistful of grain behind an empty gas can in the far corner of the barn.
大多数动物都把食物当作他们的秘密圣诞礼物。没人直接说出来，但牛注意到他们存了一点。不仅仅是残渣，而是最好的部分——马的燕麦，猪的厚面包皮。连公鸡——那个最大的贪吃鬼——也设法做了牺牲，在谷仓远角的一个空油桶后面囤积了一把谷粒。
He and the others were surely hungry, yet none of them complained about it. And this bothered the cow more than anything. How could they be so corny? She looked at the pig who sat smiling in his pen and then at the turkey who'd hung a sprig of mistletoe from the end of his waddle and was waltzing across the floor saying, "Any takers?" Even to other guys. It was his cheerfulness that irritated her the most. And so, on the morning of Christmas Eve she pulled him aside for a little talk about the future.
他和别人肯定都很饿，但没有一个抱怨。这让牛感到比什么都难受。他们怎么能这么老土？她看着猪坐在猪圈里微笑，然后看着火鸡，他从肉垂末端挂了一束槲寄生，正跳着华尔兹穿过地板说：“有人要吗？”即使是对其他雄性。他的快乐最让她心烦。所以，平安夜那天早上，她把他拉到一边，谈了谈未来。
"The farmer will be cutting your head off at around noon," she said. "His son wanted him to use a chainsaw, but he's a traditionalist so we'll probably be sticking with the axe." The turkey laughed, thinking it was a joke. But then he saw the pleasure in the cow's face and knew that she was telling the truth.
“农夫大约中午会砍下你的头，”她说。“他儿子想让他用链锯，但他是个传统主义者，所以我们可能会用斧头。”火鸡笑了，以为是在开玩笑。但随后他看到了牛脸上的快乐，知道她说的是实话。
"How long have you known?" he asked.
“你早就知道了？”他问。
"A few weeks," the cow told him. "I meant to tell you earlier, but what with all the excitement, I guess I forgot."
“几周了，”牛告诉他。“我本打算早点告诉你的，但因为太兴奋，我想我忘了。”
"Kill me and eat me?" The cow nodded. The turkey removed the mistletoe from the end of his waddle. "Well, golly," he said, "Don't I feel stupid?"
“杀了我吃了？”牛点点头。火鸡摘下了肉垂末端的槲寄生。“好吧，天哪，”他说，“我不觉得自己很蠢吗？”
Not wanting to spoil anyone's Christmas, the turkey announced that he would be spending the holiday with relatives, "The wild side of the family," he said, "Just flew in last night from Kentucky."
为了不扫大家的兴，火鸡宣布他将和亲戚过节，“野外的那一拨亲戚，”他说，“昨晚刚从肯塔基飞来。”
When noon arrived and the farmer showed up, he followed him out of the barn without complaint saying, "So long everyone," and "See you in a few days." They all waved goodbye except for the cow, who lowered her head toward her empty trough. She was just thinking that a little extra food might be nice when a horrible thought occurred to her.
当中午到来，农夫出现时，他毫无怨言地跟着他出了谷仓说：“再见啦，大家，”和“几天后再见。”他们都挥手告别，除了牛，她把头垂向她空空的槽。她正想着要是多给点食物就好了，这时一个可怕的念头闪过脑海。
The rooster was standing in the doorway and she almost trampled him on her way outside shouting, "Wait, come back. Whose name did you draw?"
公鸡正站在门口，她在冲出去时差点踩到他，大喊：“等等，回来。你抽到了谁的名字？”
"Say, what?" the turkey said.
“什么？”火鸡说。
"I said, whose name did you get? Who's supposed to receive your secret Santa present?"
“我说，你拿到了谁的名字？谁该收到你的秘密圣诞礼物？”
"You'll see," the turkey said, his voice a little song that hung in the air long after he disappeared.
“你会看到的，”火鸡说，他的声音像一首小曲，在他消失后很久仍悬在空中。
David Sedaris. He has a collection of Christmas stories called Holiday s on Ice . His most recent book is Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim .
大卫·塞达里斯。他有一本圣诞故事集叫《冰上假期》。他最近的一本书是《穿灯芯绒和牛仔裤的家人》。
Of course, no Christmas extravaganza could be complete without a new Christmas carol. And we have one from writer Sarah Vowell, author of two books of historical essays-- the most recent, Assassination Vacation . And this song is not just about Christmas, it's also about patriotism and supporting our troops, our troops in the Revolutionary War that is. These ones were not far from Philadelphia and-- incredible as it may seem-- there was a time when we would send American soldiers into battle without proper equipment and supplies. The band Marah composed and performed the music. Sarah did the lyrics.
当然，没有一首新的圣诞颂歌，圣诞庆典就不完整。我们邀请了作家莎拉·沃威尔，她是两本历史散文集的作者——最近的一本是《刺杀假期》。这首歌不仅是关于圣诞节，也是关于爱国主义和支持我们的军队，也就是独立战争中的军队。这些军队离费城不远，而且——看起来不可思议——曾经有一段时间，我们会把美国士兵送上前线，却不给他们提供适当的装备和补给。马拉乐队负责作曲和演奏。莎拉负责作词。
[MUSIC-"CHRISTMAS AT VALLEY FORGE" BY MARAH]
[音乐 - 马拉乐队演唱的《福吉谷的圣诞节》]
[SINGING] If you cracked your teeth on fruitcake and Santa did you wrong, listen up, kids, you'll forget your crummy little Christmas after you hear this song.
[演唱] 如果你把牙齿磕在水果蛋糕上，圣诞老人又对不住你，听好了，孩子们，听完这首歌，你就会忘了你那该死的圣诞节。
General, General General George. Valley, Valley, Valley Forge.
将军，将军，乔治将军。福吉，福吉，福吉谷。
'Twas 1777 and the general's name was George. His shoeless, shirtless army starved and froze at Valley Forge. Barefoot marched through the winter woods with the snow like candy canes, but the red and white tracks weren't peppermint sticks, they were blood stains. George Washington and the Marquis de Lafayette crooned a "Baby It's Cold Outside," duet.
那是1777年，将军的名字叫乔治。他那双脚无鞋、身上无衣的军队在福吉谷挨饿受冻。赤脚走过冬日的森林，雪像糖果手杖，但红白相间的轨迹不是薄荷糖，而是血迹。乔治·华盛顿和拉法耶特侯爵对唱着《宝贝，外面很冷》。
"You're hands are like ice," sang the Marquis to George. That was Christmas at Valley Forge. You can't deck the halls when you have no halls. It's a real blue Christmas when your lips turn blue. The yanks were spared from red coat attack, but alas, not from the flu. And dysentary too.
“你的手像冰一样，”侯爵对乔治唱道。那就是福吉谷的圣诞节。当你没有大厅时，你不能装饰大厅。当你的嘴唇变蓝时，这是一个真正的忧郁圣诞。扬基队免遭红衫军袭击，但唉，没能逃过流感。还有痢疾。
Well, they didn't have blankets and they slept in tents, and it's not a merry Christmas if you long for Lent. Alone in the woods, Washington prayed, "Lord, for heaven sakes, make us free, make us warm, make us Philly cheesesteaks."
嗯，他们没有毯子，睡在帐篷里，如果你渴望大斋期，那可不是快乐的圣诞节。华盛顿独自在树林里祈祷，“上帝啊，看在天堂份上，让我们自由，让我们温暖，给我们费城芝士牛排吧。”
So if Yuletide fills you with jitters and fear, just recall the brave men in that terrible year. They started out a country, defeated the Brits, and Christmas has been so much better, better ever since.
所以如果节日让你充满不安和恐惧，回想一下那个可怕年份里勇敢的人们。他们建立了一个国家，打败了英国人，从此圣诞节变得好多了，好多了。
George Washington and the Marquis de Lafayette crooned a "Baby It's Cold Outside," duet.
乔治·华盛顿和拉法耶特侯爵对唱着《宝贝，外面很冷》。
"Your hands are like ice," sang the Marquis to George. That was Christmas-- that was Christmas-- that was Christmas at Valley Forge.
“你的手像冰一样，”侯爵对乔治唱道。那就是圣诞节——那就是圣诞节——那就是福吉谷的圣诞节。
Marah, performing a song with lyrics by Sarah Vowell. Marah has an album of Christmas songs that does not include this song, but includes all of the other songs you're hearing this hour and many more, called Christmas Kind of Town .
马拉乐队，演唱了莎拉·沃威尔作词的歌曲。马拉乐队有一张圣诞歌曲专辑，不包括这首歌，但包括你这小时听到的所有其他歌曲，还有更多，叫《圣诞小镇》。
And this brings us to our very last story in our Christmas Spectacular-- the inevitable story that we all know so well-- this time retold by Jonathan Goldstein.
这把我们带到了我们圣诞特别节目的最后一个故事——我们都非常熟悉的故事——这次由乔纳森·戈德斯坦重述。
The thing with pregnant women is that they glow. I know you've heard this, how they walk around like uranium Buddhas, spreading joy and light. But the way my Mary glowed was for real. Mary was like the sunrise. And when she smiled her kind little smile, you had to literally shield your eyes. Another thing about pregnant women-- or at least it's something I've noticed with Mary-- is that they're supremely confident, like their bellies are puffed-out barrel chests and they're looking for a tussle, but a tussle that will end in bear hugs. Because not only are they confident, but they're filled with love. Mary sometimes calls me over while I'm sanding a chair or something and just quietly strokes the side of my face.
怀孕女性的特点是发光。我知道你听过这个，她们如何像铀做成的佛像一样走来走去，传播欢乐和光明。但我那玛丽发出的光是真实的。玛丽就像日出。当她露出那种善良的小微笑时，你不得不从字面上遮住眼睛。关于怀孕女性的另一件事——至少是我在玛丽身上注意到的——是她们极度自信，就像她们的肚子是高高鼓起的桶形胸膛，她们在寻找一场争斗，但那种会以熊抱结束的争斗。因为她们不仅自信，而且充满了爱。玛丽有时在我打磨椅子之类的东西时叫我过去，只是静静地抚摸我的脸颊。
"You're OK?" she asks.
“你还好吗？”她问。
"Of course I'm OK," I say, "I'm the one who should be asking if you're OK." But of course, I know what she's getting at.
“我当然好，”我说，“我才是那个该问你还好吗的人。”但当然，我知道她要说什么。
"How's the holy baby?" Ezekiel-- my foreman at work-- asks me, like 10 times a day. And I have no choice but to bite it. It's either that or be out of a job. Being chosen by the Lord is an honor. I'm not saying it's not. It's flattering to think that your girlfriend is good enough for God. But if the guys at work don't act like it's an honor, and none of your friends or family acts like it's an honor, it stops feeling like an honor. And so you end up just feeling like your everyday, garden variety guy who has been cheated on. Sure, you've been cheated on with the Lord, but still.
“圣婴怎么样了？”以西结——我工作时的工头——问我，一天大概问10遍。我别无选择，只能忍着。要么忍着，要么丢掉工作。被上帝选中是一种荣誉。我不是说不是。想到你的女朋友足够好，能怀上上帝的孩子是件令人受宠若惊的事。但如果同事们不表现得这是一种荣誉，如果你身边的朋友或家人都不把它当作荣誉，它就不再感觉像荣誉了。所以你最终只会觉得你是个被戴了绿帽子的普通人。当然，你是被上帝戴了绿帽子，但那也还是。
I should also say that even getting to the point where I believed Mary was an ulcer wrapped in a hernia. She had never lied to me before. And I knew her heart like I knew my own. But when she told me this business about being visited by an angel, I had an honest to God conniption.
我也得说，即使是相信玛丽怀孕这件事也是一种疝气包着溃疡的折磨。她以前从没对我撒过谎。我了解她的心，就像了解我自己的心一样。但当她告诉我这个被天使拜访的事情时，我真的爆发了。
"Is that the best you can come up with?" I asked. "Don't you have enough respect for me to create something a little less-- I don't know-- completely insane?"
“这就是你能想到的最好的借口了吗？”我问。“你就不能对我有点尊重，创造一个不那么——我不知道——完全疯癫的故事吗？”
She stared through me as though in a dream. My dad used to say that Mary was like a sleepwalker, sleeping while she was eating, while she worked, while you talked to her. I went outside to try and cool off. Sitting on a tree stump, I felt a hand on my shoulder. I turned around and there he was, an angel-- the whole bit, wings and everything-- just squatting there. Talk about a lack of stagecraft. I almost went back to chewing on my knuckle skin and ignoring him entirely.
她穿过我看着远方，仿佛在做梦。我爸爸常说玛丽像个梦游者，吃东西时在睡，工作时在睡，你跟她说话时她在睡。我走到外面想冷静一下。坐在树桩上，我感到肩膀上有只手。我转过身，他就在那里，一个天使——全是那一套，翅膀什么的——就蹲在那里。谈谈什么叫缺乏舞台效果。我差点回去咬我的指关节，完全无视他。
"Are you the one?" I asked, not looking at him, "With Mary?"
“你是那个吗？”我问，没看他，“和玛丽在一起的那个？”
"No," he said softly. "I just came here to tell you that what Mary says is the truth."
“不是，”他轻声说。“我只是来告诉你玛丽说的是实话。”
"This is a lot to digest," I said. The angel withdrew his hand from my shoulder and left me sitting there outside my house, digesting until morning.
“这太难消化了，”我说。天使把手从我的肩膀上拿开，留我一个人坐在屋外，一直消化到早晨。
Even after all that I was still a mess. "What did the angel look like?" I'd ask every so often.
即使在那之后，我也依然是个烂摊子。“天使长什么样？”我时不时会问。
"What difference does that make?" she'd say.
“那有什么区别吗？”她会说。
"I just want to know," I'd say. In the early days, I was all about the little details. What was he wearing? What did he say to you? Was he a handsome angel? What do you mean there was a blinding flash of heavenly light?
“我只是想知道，”我会说。在早期，我全神贯注于小细节。他穿什么？他对你说了什么？他是个英俊的天使吗？你说的耀眼的圣光是什么意思？
So it was pretty soon afterwards that I moved on from jealousy to worry. Who was I to be raising an angel baby? What could I teach a baby of any kind? Worry that the baby might not even look like people, that he might be born with wings, or worse, be born with just one wing. The thought of Mary holding a one-winged baby on her lap was just about enough to make me get all weepy and sick to my stomach. If that son-of-a-bitch Ezekiel made even one little crack about my illegitimate, one-winged baby-- job or no job-- I'd strangle him with my bare hands.
所以没过多久，我就从嫉妒转为了担忧。我算什么人，竟然要养育一个天使婴儿？我能教任何种类的婴儿什么？我担心孩子可能看起来不像人，担心他可能带着翅膀出生，或者更糟，只带了一只翅膀出生。想到玛丽膝盖上抱着一只翅膀的婴儿，就足以让我泪流满面、胃里翻江倒海。如果那个混蛋以西结敢对我的私生单翅婴儿开哪怕一点点玩笑——工作不工作都无所谓——我就要亲手勒死他。
Now the very last thing I needed in the midst of all this was to load up the mule and take Mary and myself out of town for a census. The Romans were obsessed with counting things. And so everyone had to pack up and be counted in their city of birth, which for Mary and me was Bethlehem. What a sight, the two of us hobbling along on a mule. Did you know that a mule is the offspring of a horse and a donkey? It's a hybrid like the way a Pegasus is a hybrid, the offspring of a horse and-- I'm guessing-- an eagle. Now, can you imagine how that Pegasus' horse's mother's horse husband felt when the eagle first swooped down with roses and sweet talk? Do you see what I'm getting at here? I'm just going to stop myself now.
现在，在我经历这一切的时候，最不需要的就是套上骡子，带着玛丽和我自己出城去进行人口普查。罗马人沉迷于数东西。所以每个人都必须收拾行李去他们的出生城市被清点，我和玛丽的就是伯利恒。多么壮观啊，我们俩在那头骡子上蹒跚而行。你知道骡子是马和驴的后代吗？它是混血儿，就像天马是混血儿一样，它是马和——我猜是——鹰的后代。现在，你能想象当鹰第一次带着玫瑰和甜言蜜语俯冲而下时，那匹天马的母亲的马丈夫是什么感受吗？你明白我的意思了吗？我现在要闭嘴了。
When we got to Bethlehem, it was like everyone and their Uncle Nimrod was there. Every place in town was booked. But on the edge of the city we found a little dive. And it was there-- exhausted after a day of refusals-- that I decided I simply wasn't going to take no for an answer. Mary saw how I was getting, the stress vein on my forehead two seconds from bursting. And so she kept telling me how everything was going to be OK. But of course, when you're living half in a dream, frolicking with the angels, you can sleep on a mule, on a daisy, on the head of the pin. Me? I deal with cold, hard reality. And if I can't even get a lousy bed for us, what kind of a job am I going to do for Mary and the kid?
当我们到达伯利恒时，就像全世界的人和他们的尼姆罗德叔叔都在那儿一样。城里所有地方都订满了。但在城市边缘，我们找到了一个破地方。就在那里——在经历了拒绝的一天后我精疲力竭——我决定我绝不接受不。玛丽看到我变得怎样，我额头上那根压力血管差两秒就要爆开了。所以她一直告诉我一切都会没事的。但当然，当你活在梦里，和天使嬉戏时，你可以在骡子上睡觉，在雏菊上睡觉，在针尖上睡觉。我呢？我面对的是冰冷、残酷的现实。如果我连一张像样的床都搞不到，我还能给玛丽和孩子做什么？
A little bearded man greeted us at the door. Right off the bat, he raised his hand blocking me. "No dice," he said.
一个留着胡子的小个子男人在门口迎接我们。他直接举起手挡住我。“不行，”他说。
"Listen," I said, putting half my body through the door frame. "You have to have something. I have a pregnant wife here." He looked over my shoulder at Mary on the mule. And he took pity on us. He handed us a blanket and told us that we could say in his stable. A stable. The word was like a gob of spit dripping off my eyelashes. Tears of rage burned my throat. A stable. I've worked my whole life only to have my wife give birth to an angel-baby in a lousy manger.
“听着，”我说，把半个身体探进门框。“你必须有什么。我这儿有个怀孕的妻子。”他看向我身后在骡子上的玛丽。他同情我们。他递给我们一条毯子，告诉我们可以在他的马厩里休息。马厩。这个词就像从我睫毛上滴落的一口唾沫。愤怒的泪水烧灼着我的喉咙。马厩。我奋斗了一辈子，竟然让我妻子在一个破马槽里生下天使婴儿。
Inside the stable, the animals were completely silent-- not asleep, just quiet. I don't know if you've ever been in a room full of silent animals, but it's eerie and unnatural. I looked at them and they looked back at me.
在马厩里，动物们完全沉默——不是在睡觉，只是安静。我不知道你有没有在一个全是沉默动物的房间里待过，但这很阴森、很不自然。我看着它们，它们也看着我。
"You know," said Mary in the quiet, "I really feel like things are going to be different somehow, after this baby is born."
“你知道，”玛丽在寂静中说，“我真的觉得事情会变得不同，在这个婴儿出生后。”
"That's the way it goes," I said, clumping up some hay for us. "My dad used to say that too. 'After the kids are born' he'd say, 'Nothing is ever the same.'"
“事情总是这样，”我说，给我们堆了一些干草。“我爸以前也常说。‘孩子出生后’他说，‘没有什么会保持原样了。’”
"I just feel," Mary went on, "That this is a very special kid we've got here."
“我只是觉得，”玛丽继续说，“我们怀的这个是个非常特别的孩子。”
"All mothers feel that way," I said.
“所有母亲都这么觉得，”我说。
"I know."
“我知道。”
"Looking at you in this stable, I could just punch myself in the face," I said. Mary reached out and rubbed the side of my face. She did it like she always did, like an old man. Her hand was cold.
“看着你在这个马厩里，我真想给自己一拳，”我说。玛丽伸出手摸了摸我的脸。她像往常一样，像个老头子一样摸着。她的手很冷。
"I'm just so happy you're here," she whispered.
“我真高兴你在这里，”她低语道。
"I know." I turned over onto my stomach and Mary started in on the knots in my back. As she rubbed, I complained and told her my worries. And as I complained, she laughed. And the sound of Mary's laughter was like angels' wings clapping. And for the first time in a long time, it felt like things were going to be OK. In about three minutes, I'd be asleep. And sometime after that, Mary would be too, her head resting on my back. The thing with me and Mary is that whenever we fall asleep, somehow, in the middle of the night, we end up holding hands. And that night in the stable, when Mary woke in the darkness with a sudden start, like always, our fingers were entwined.
“我知道。”我翻过身趴着，玛丽开始按压我背上的结。当她揉的时候，我抱怨着，告诉她我的担忧。当我抱怨时，她笑了。玛丽的笑声就像天使的翅膀在拍打。这是很久以来第一次，感觉一切都会没事的。大约三分钟后，我就会睡着了。在那之后不久，玛丽也会睡着，头靠在我的背上。我和玛丽的特点是，无论什么时候我们睡着，总会在深夜里不知不觉地牵着手。那晚在马厩里，当玛丽在黑暗中突然惊醒时，像往常一样，我们的手指交缠在一起。
And when Mary squeezed my hand, I sprang into action.
当玛丽握紧我的手时，我迅速行动起来。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the CBC program WireTap , which we can hear here in the United States on Sirius Satellite Radio, channel 137.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦是CBC节目《WireTap》的主持人，我们可以在美国的Sirius卫星广播137频道听到。
Our Christmas Spectacular was produced by Jane Feltes, Diane Cook, and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Chris Sliden Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder.
我们的圣诞特别节目由简·费尔特斯、黛安·库克和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、莎拉·柯尼格、克里斯·斯莱登、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克参与。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持列表]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who hopes that all of the shows that we've done in 10 years,
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督者托雷·马拉蒂亚，他希望我们在10年里做的所有节目，
Have made folks forget both the vomit and tears.
都能让人们忘记那时的呕吐和泪水。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，继续收听《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。